you are not going to believe this or you
are
and maybe that's really the problem that
it's very believable
yesterday joe biden's administration uh
made a major announcement
on vaccination this is not the
surprising part i'll get you to the
surprising part in a moment uh the
administration of joe biden
has been delivering hugely when it comes
to coronavirus vaccines
joe biden initially said the goal is a
hundred million doses in a hundred days
now at the time i said
we're sort of like already on track for
89 million so it's not super ambitious
but
then he doubled that goal to 200 million
doses in 100 days
joe biden then moved up the full
eligibility date to may 1st and
yesterday joe biden
moved it up even further announcing that
as of now
on april 19th there will be full
adult eligibility for coronavirus
vaccines
in all 50 states regardless of age
regardless of occupation regardless of
health status
and that is a really big deal we are now
giving doses to roughly one percent of
the entire u.s population
every single day about 3 million doses
per day
huge announcement incredible success
with the accelerating vaccination
program under this administration and
when joe biden finishes
telling the united states about this
great news
peter ducey from fox news when joe biden
finishes up gets up and yells at joe
biden
should the masters golf tournament be
moved out of georgia
what yeah that's what peter ducey
urgently yelled at joe biden after a
momentous
announcement with regard to vaccines and
joe biden handles it well we're going to
look at it
and joe biden's approach has been the
right one to this boycott stuff from the
beginning
joe biden says companies should do what
they want to do
i support businesses deciding what's
best for them
it's almost like a conservative position
but the voter suppression has to stop
check out the exchange and remember
biden's event was about vaccines biden
wasn't scheduled to take questions
biden is under no obligation to answer
stupid questions yelled at him by peter
ducey
but he does anyway despite the right
narrative the right wing narrative being
that joe biden won't answer any
questions from reporters take a look at
this
the master's golf tournament should be
moved out of georgia
i think that's up to the masters
look
you know it is reassuring
to see that
for-profit operations and businesses
are speaking up about how
these new jim crow laws are just
antithetical to who we are there's
another side to it too
the other side to it too is when they in
fact move
out of georgia the people who need to
help the most
people who are making hourly wages
sometimes get hurt the most i think it's
a very tough decision for a corporation
to make
or a group to make but i respect them
when they make that judgment
and i support whatever judgment they
make but it's
the best way to deal with this is for
georgia and
other states to smarten up stop it
stop it it's about getting people
you know in a sense conservatives should
love that answer these are
for-profit businesses making
you know the the apple of the republican
eye is the for-profit business
and it's a for-profit business making
the decision they want to make
and then dealing with whatever
consequences come of it period another
thing
joe biden does well there is once he
gets
out of the way the reminder that these
are private businesses deciding things
for themselves
he gets back to the core issue and i
think that this is something that
we should always be doing when this
issue comes up
which is the core issue is republicans
didn't get enough votes in 2020 or what
i mean by that is
they didn't suppress enough votes in
2020
in particular this happened in georgia
joe biden took georgia first democratic
presidential candidate
in a long time to win georgia two
democratic challengers
unseated two republican incumbent
senators in georgia
and so republicans are now trying to
suppress the vote even more
we have more than 250 voter suppression
bills across the country
that's also happening in georgia and joe
biden puts the focus on that that's
exactly what he should be doing
one bonus clip here joe biden after the
same
event is asked if he's spoken or met
with
federal reserve chairman jay powell
jerome powell he goes by jay
and joe biden says no and he explains
you know the fed is supposed to be
independent like understanding the
genesis of these organizations
biden doesn't want to get too involved
with the fed
and certainly isn't going to be telling
them what to do the way that donald
trump did take a listen to this
last spoken to the question
reserve chairman jay powell yet i have
not
can you say why i am not
look i think the the federal reserve was
an independent operation
and starting off my presidency i want to
be real clear
that i'm not going to do the kinds of
things that have been done in the last
administration
either talking to the attorney general
about who he's going to prosecute or not
prosecute
and under what circumstances or the fed
telling them what they should and
shouldn't do
even though that wouldn't be the basis
upon which i'd be talking to them
so i've been very fastidious about not
talking to them but i do talk
to the secretary of treasury thank you
all very
uh you mentioned much i was pleasantly
surprised
i've had my criticisms of joe biden so
far i've had my praise
biden wasn't even scheduled to take
questions he wasn't expected to take
questions he did
and he made some principles very clear
in ways that i don't think reporters
particularly liked
because it gave them nothing and joe
biden he almost seems to enjoy
toying with peter ducey who by the way
i mean if back when you had reporters
yelling questions at trump like that you
had fox and others saying it's
disrespectful
it's disrespectful to yell out questions
like that to the president they
they seem thrilled the right does with
peter ducey's questions and joe biden
handling them very well
i want to do one more peter ducey
segment next
because it actually relates to a really
important discussion about georgia
colorado the all-star game and more
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company a
randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information
so this allows you to keep your banking
information secure but also to take
control of your finances you can create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at
privacy.com slash pacman